okay so let's take a closer look now at
the belgium-based swift international
payment system swift stands for the
society for worldwide interbank
financial telecommunication banks around
the world use it to make secure
cross-border payments removing some
russian banks from swift will make it
almost impossible for them to send money
in or out of the country this will
impair the ability of russian companies
and their foreign customers to trade and
will particularly affect russia's oil
and gas exports iran was removed from
swift back in 2014 over the country's
nuclear program financial analysts say
iran lost almost half of its oil export
revenue and 30 percent of its foreign
trade as a result let's bring in
lawrence kotlikov who's a professor of
economics at boston university he joins
us from providence rhode island thanks
for being on the program professor let's
take a closer look now at these
sanctions
what impact will blocking access to
swift have on moscow
well i think it's going to be part of uh
you know it's basically
a decision on the part of the of europe
and the us
and and its allies in other parts of the
world australia new zealand to stop
importing and stop ex
importing from russia or exporting to
russia
and swift is an aspect of that but
uh you know even if they come up with
some other
way to do transactions if
uh you know these governments will say
we're going to put an embargo on imports
and exports that's the next thing that's
going to come
so
it's going to be russia
perhaps working with china but china is
going to be probably very hesitant
because they'll realize that uh
if they side with russia in this uh then
they could also be embargoed so we could
end up in a in the extreme if we have
uh you know with a russian china
basically with a few buddies uh and the
rest of the world
and that's gonna go very badly for both
of those countries
you mentioned briefly where to from here
what other financial punishments could
be implemented against russia there's
obviously the option for the eu to
sharply reduce the purchase of russian
oil and natural gas but then would that
be too costly for the eu given it
receives a third of its energy from
moscow
well i think they may you know
i think this is going to happen through
time so perhaps in may they will
just the germans will decide to stop
importing gas when it's no longer needed
to heat germany and they will start
reactivating their nuclear reactors uh
for nuclear energy there's lots of
res you know there are responses to
coming up with ways to get energy even
in
the medium term
but yes it would be a sacrifice in the
part of uh
western europe but they appear to be
willing to to make the sacrifice with
respect to
the price of energy going sky high
and uh that'll happen in the u.s too i
think
i think it's just going to become so
toxic for anybody to do anything with
russia
any u.s company any european company
imports exports i think you're going to
see
russia you know basically putin's being
viewed as adolf hitler in this context
and with good reason
uh because he's
you know this is a
1939 all over again
you mentioned how some of those
sanctions
could hurt the west too and come at a
cost of their own economies is that the
ugly reality of of war and will western
leaders and citizens be more willing to
accept those economic costs
well i think you know to some extent
uh
if china and
if china sides with russia and uh
there's an embargo on china as well then
you
us and european companies get rid of a
major competitor
so we have more production occurring in
those regions
and so in some ways it's good for the us
economy and the european economy
it really depends on
you know russia is not a big player in
the world economy
i think so one question is big question
is how does china react and is there
going to be reaction to how china reacts
uh from the west
and will this deter
you know china may learn from this
experience that
invading taiwan is going to be extremely
costly costly to them
because they'll get the same reaction
from the west
that russia is having so there's lots of
very interesting implications here what
i see happening most likely is russia's
entirely isolated and uh
maybe some
uh somebody in the military in russia
decides this is uh
putin's gone far enough we don't need to
have
one person drag us into this kind of
situation that destroys the russian
economy
and uh i mean aeroflot cannot land in
any uh european uh
cities as far as i can tell they won't
be able to come to the us
nobody from russia will be able to leave
russia to the west uh in terms of just
travel
so there's so many implications and it's
already happening very quickly
i i think he's overplayed his hand here
dramatically
and i think he's
kind of lost it mentally
from that speech he gave and uh
calling ukrainians nazis you have the
the president of ukraine is uh
jewish and his parents survived his
parents were i think relatives were
killed in the holocaust he's hardly a
nazi
yes it's certainly going to be
interesting to see how the coming days
and weeks unfold thank you for your
analysis there lawrence kotlikov
professor of economics at boston
university